vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel bien qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sf mais nous
sans filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut que nos invités dati site
super content avec moins d'hommes
plantes
on est en mode distanciation social vous
allez voir le podcast on a en fait on a
réouvert le studio premier podcast dans
le studio qui sort do c'est vraiment ça
fait du bien à venir ici on sent bien
siemens et le funky c'est plus fun
parler de quelqu'un dans le blanc des
yeux que partout ouais vraiment n'ayez
crainte gagne on ne prend toutes les
mesures de distanciation sociale
possible les petits pas officier qu'on
utilise pour nos micros sont désinfectés
après chaque invité on lave la table
après chaque invité jamais plus que
quatre personnes dans le studio puis on
garde nos distances
on n'est jamais plus que 3 par podcast
on a décidé de mettre une personne au
bout de la table de personnes comme ça
donc eu aucun problème de salinité aussi
usf donc inquiétez vous pas pour ça le
podcast de cette semaine et présenté par
vegan mais pas plaques tombe 2 c'est
notre deuxième livre de recettes afghane
mais peuplades donc 80 recettes
savoureuses facile simple affaire on
avait une règle en écrivant ce livre la
piste une règle que notre distante de
données puisque je dois capable de
trouver tous les ingrédients dans le jir
de stoneham
c'est extrêmement précis comme règle de
leur bureau est à stoneham
donc il fallait être capable de trouver
tous les ingrédients donc si vous avez
pas besoin des mêmes marchés spécialisés
c'est des ingrédients ultra simple à
trouver des recettes faciles à faire
savoureuse des maquettes chijs des
lasagnes des saucisses des gâteaux des
mouches
ddd gouffre de tous littéralement de
tout pour tout le monde donc si vous
voulez réduire votre consommation de
produits d'origine animale vegan mais
peuple à tourner de la livraison est
gratuite jusqu'au 4 juin donc jusqu'à
jeudi vous allez entendre ce mardi le 2
fait que coûte et vous savez que ce que
vous avez à faire on va mettre le lien
dans la description de ce podcast ici
sinon d'hommes
notre premier invité dans le studio sf
depuis la réouverture la première éviter
aujourd'hui c'est webster est important
pour nous de parler avec lui parce qu'en
ce moment il se passe quelque chose se
passe des choses dans le monde qui sont
importantes qui sont graves qui sont
difficiles qui ont pouvait pas ne pas en
parler
on peut pas faire que ne s'était pas je
pense que c'est qu'avant une tribune je
pense qu'on a une responsabilité de
tanks et des choses importantes comme
ceux de omeyer dans l'incapacité de
connaissances les aborder puis quelle
meilleure personne pour aborder c'est si
ces problématiques la queue webster 1go
fascinant un rapport un historien
conférence ea 1 go connais l'histoire
noire l'histoire générale l'histoire de
l'esclavagisme sur le bout de ses doigts
un gars qui avait cuit qui vit le
racisme encore aujourd'hui le profilage
qui arrivent au québec
encore encore aujourd'hui
c'était un espèce de classe de maître de
deux incroyables cd fascinant un gars
avec tellement de savoir qu' une belle
analyse de tous ce terrain privé là j'ai
dû parler puis on est super contents
d'avoir reçu tout à fait une des choses
que j'ai dites en fait la seule chose
qui était dit par rapport aux événements
qui se passe en ce moment aux états unis
dans les sur mes réseaux dans les
derniers jours c'était de dire qu'il y
avait des voix qui s'élevaient en ce
moment il fallait les écouter webster si
l'une de ses voiles c'est une personne
qui ont un symbole un fini pratiquement
pique tout le monde doit écouter parce
que dans ces conversations là moi j'ai
appris énormément c'est un podcast où
c'était l'occasion de justement de poser
des questions puis après ce écouter -
exactement
exactement écoutez l'on va avoir
plusieurs podcast qu'on enregistre en
banque
cette semaine si vous voulez y avoir
accès en primeur
vous pouvez vous diriger hp tu en as un
podcast avec jay du temple qui va être
sur la page mais tu es très
prochainement si si nicole déjà mis mon
sais pas s'ils vont travailler ce soir
tu dois le mettre là il fait signe que
non que ce repas en ligne demain matin
mais il va quand même en ligne
prochainement donc voir des podcasts sur
la page piquionne qui vont être là en
avance en primeur c'est la meilleure
façon nous encourager il ya du contenu
là dessus depuis m'ont fait des podcasts
exclusif sinon partager dans les
commentaires
les seigneuries thing ainsi de partager
à participer pardon à la discussion
on aime soit on entend ce que vous avez
à dire aujourd'hui c'est un sujet
extrêmement sensible
donc faites le dans le plus grand
respect possible
puis évidemment parler d'autre chose que
vous connaissez pas piti nous on le fait
de avec les meilleures intentions là
dedans tout à fait qu' on est vraiment
attristés par par le meurtre de john
gobbi
puis par la situation des noirs depuis
longtemps on veut juste titre la
meilleure chose sans savoir exactement
quoi faire mais on
bref voici voici notre conversation m
bih j'espère que vous vous apporter
autant que nous importons
[Musique]
arrête de faire plaisir mais s'il me
recevoir dernière minute on aime ça
comme sur wii ben cotton et flexible
tout ça aujourd'hui a été telle en
demande beaucoup j'imagine que en fait
ton expertise pita connaissance de
l'histoire et on ne peut plus importante
dans les moments qu'on vit en ce moment
ouais je pense que l'histoire permet de
comprendre qu'est ce qui se passe là que
tout ce qui se passe en ce moment est
indissociable de l'histoire des états
unis ouais mais des amériques de
l'europe de l'afrique du monde
aquatiques en fait on ne peut pas de
dégâts chez ceux du de la trame
historique c'est difficile en tant que
québécois de de voir cette grande et
cette grande pictures cette grande image
de l'histoire at large qui décide de la
mieux la saisir les way et c'est ça que
je trouve particulier parce que on fait
partie cette histoire là aussi - fait
jeudi en une le lavage ici les esclaves
qui venaient ici
était il y avait des autochtones qui
venait de ce qui est maintenant le
midwest américain
il y avait des noirs aussi qu'ils
venaient des antilles qui venait des
treize colonies et certains qui sont nés
en afrique
donc j'en faisais partie de ce réseau là
jésus à leurs hommes qu'on buvait ici le
sucre que manger ici l'est des antilles
étaient cultivés par les esclaves soi
même dans les années 1800 la morue de
mauvaise qualité qui étaient pêchées en
gaspésie est envoyé dans les plantations
dans les antilles jusqu'au brésil fact
et la morue de bonne qualité est envoyé
en europe puis pour pouvoir passer la
mauvaise qualité on envoyait pour
nourrir les esclaves pour qu'ils aient
des protéines ou sheep troc excellent
élément dans ce sens
maintenant cette histoire fait partie de
notre histoire aussi - puis même dans
l'histoire récente si on parle de
brutalité policière si on me parle de
gens qui ont été tués deux personnes
noires qui ont été tués il y en a ici
les émeutes raciales
il y en a eu ici on parle de la meute
assure john williams université
concordia et riads et des étudiants
noirs qui se sont rebellés parce que et
des enseignants qui leur donne
automatiquement des mauvaises notes et
ça fait partie de notre histoire mais le
problème c'est que tout ça a été rayée
parce que c'est beaucoup je t'aime à
l'argumentaire ou est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui ressort en ce moment
là qu'on observe ce qui se passe pitié
on l'entend ceci oui mais faut pas
nécessairement appliquer ce qui se passe
aux etats unis si je pense que je pense
qu'on peut quand même peut-être
s'entendent sur le fait que l'histoire
est du pays différence mais faut pas non
plus nier ce qui s'est passé ici puis
toi et te dirais même temps la situation
canada au québec verse et celles aux
etats-unis c'est quoi la différence
c'est que les ressemblances non bah tu
vois ça dépend de quelle approche on
prend cette version on parle de
l'esclavagé aux états unis le slave
acheter un esclavage des plantations en
esclavage économique tandis qu'ici c'est
un esclavage domestique
c'est des gens qui étaient dans les
maisons qui servaient des repas chat
erreur parce que j'en avais pas le
climat
pour avoir les plantations mais si on
avait eu plus ma bien sûr qu'on aurait
dit oui parce que j'ai les mêmes gens
qui venaient ici et elles mêmes gens qui
partaient en martinique qui partait en
guadeloupe haïti et donc on pense
toujours que notre histoire est
tellement différente mais oui à des
différences mais des similitudes aussi
par les mentalités d'époque et je le
regarde je sais ce qui se passe avec les
autochtones aussi les violences
policières qui ont la vue à rouen il ya
quelques années envers les femmes
autochtones nous propre dynamique de
racisme ici et je dirais faut être
conscient que les amériques ont été
construites sur le racisme
c'est ce qui a donné à partir du moment
où les européens se sont donné le droit
de s'installer sur les terres
autochtones
qui voyait ses terres comme étant libre
pourtant il y avait des gens habitaient
toi mais à partir du moment où est ce
qu'ils se sont dit on peut venir ici
parce que ce sont des terres vierges
c'est que à partir de ce moment là tu
considère ces gens pas comme des humains
mais c'est envers ces gens ils ont le
même droit que le chevreuil dans la
forêt là tu vois et donc nos histoires
sont ancrés dans le racisme mais le
racisme au leur extirper de notre âme
historique que ce soit au canada jusqu'à
aux etats unis c'est plus difficile de
l'extirper ici ça a été plus facile de
l'extirper parce que il y avait une
moins grande population noire entre
autres dû souvent on pense au racisme
blanc noir mais il ya le racisme envers
les autochtones aussi qui est qui et qui
est très présent et donc au final notre
histoire aussi est trempé là dedans je
vous donne un exemple aussi que je
trouve fera pas c'est quand tu vu la
blague fils avec justin koua non
excusez-moi je disais non ce n'est pas
une histoire québécois se veut une
histoire canadienne le black fisc aux
états unis si vous allez dans les
journaux à partir de 1842 jusqu'à 1200
vous allez dans le daily mail que oui à
québec vous allez dans la monture herald
il ya des annonces de black fait
pratiquement chaque mois il y avait des
concerts de blagues fusent ici au
théâtre royal au nord d'amiens au music
hall à québec il y avait du black fès
pratiquement à chaque mois chaque année
on retrouve des instances de gens qui
vont sale con du blackface mais pourtant
on nous dit nombreux sports l'histoire
du si de la personne qui a composé
l'hymne national calixa-lavallée faisait
du blackface aux etats unis une carrière
de blake face aux états unis et donc on
a une grande millau pis historiquement
ici judicieusement envie de parler d'
aveuglement
reparlons de myopie pour l'instant c'est
ok qu'est ce qui a contribué à cette
myopie le web parce que j'imagine que
j'imagine que l'histoire est écrite par
la pression pour tout le temps donc
c'est sûr que tu as à ce niveau là 7
cette perception là qui veut pas être
dans l'erreur
ici on a au canada je dirais que
l'aspect francophones anglophones qui
est très présent et qui a tâté tout le
reste est donc pour ce qui est du québec
le premier a écrit vraiment une histoire
officielle du canada à l'époque on
appelait ça comme pour tout le canada
c'est françois xavier garneau qui écrit
en 1945-46 histoire du canada mais
garneau lui a écrit ça en réaction au
rapport du rhin après les rébellions de
1837 38 à ce que jean dit le peuple
canadien-français entre 400 culture son
histoire s'en passer il faut l'assimiler
c'est ce qu'ils disent et les gens
disent pas vrai on a une histoire et
garneau s'applique à écrire l'histoire
est donc ici on voit une utilisation de
l'histoire afin de remonter la fierté
nationale et se justifier par rapport à
une conquête britannique et donc garneau
va écrire nos ancêtres français n'ont
pas cru bon d'avoir des esclaves afin de
conserver la pureté notre sans toi
c'est le premier à écrire l'histoire est
écrit il ya pas eu d service il n'y a
pas eu de noirs ici puis les gens vont
me reprocher à garneau pipi même en
écrivant ça avec la formulation tu viens
d'énoncer de voir une formulation
raciste oui mais oui tout à fait oui
même si même si il ya un rêve l'esclave
âge de l'équation ça reste une
formulation complètement raciste que de
dire on veut garder la tête haute et
notre sang mais oui exact puisse dire
c'est cécité l'époque justement à dix
les années 1800 lorsque tout était venu
à la lumière de la race on parle de la
race canadienne française on paraît de
parler de la race britannique et terabox
un moment où est ce que l'idée de race
extrêmement présente est donc pour lui
ben et dix bons mètres tolérance
britanniques et canadiens et canadiennes
françaises qui sont des races pures des
rats civilisationnel
et donc de dire qu'ils auraient eu des
noirs ici qui se mélange avec les gens
tout d'un coup c'est comme si tu es
rabaisser toit jeudi à lionel groulx par
la suite avait pratiquement le même
discours et donc les grands monuments
historiques qui ont contribué à façonner
notre histoire une autre identité
étaient des racistes doivent et des
approches raciste donc ce qui fait qu
entre autres que les gens jamais été
intéressant à intéresser à raconter
cette histoire là et ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que les premiers à
parler d' esclavage ici sont jacques
viger le premier maire de montréal et
louis hippolyte lafontaine en 1859 le
livre fascicule qui s'appelle de
l'esclavagé en canada et donc mais
apparemment que ça va se perdre entre
les craques que ça bascule à parce que
finalement une trame narrative
collective va se situer au delà de
l'esclavagé à dire qu' on n'est plus
dans une dynamique de négation soit on
n'est plus en train de nier
on est en train d'en ne peut ni dans le
néant on ne nie pas on est passé dans
l'obscurité totale et jenson ni dans
l'oubli exactement effacé oublié les
gens là ne savent plus toi et donc pour
moi c'est un peu ce qui explique le fait
qu'on en parle pas juste le fait tiquer
des erreurs sont commises comme
justement tiff le couple d'années le
black fait c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
le symptôme d'un manque de connaissances
historiques tout de même de même pas
savoir que cette pratique le est
offensante et est pas correct c'est
vraiment du juste juste ménagés n'ont
jamais avoir entendu parler seppi il ya
un problème problématique le temps que
tu peux te rendent à l'âge adulte sans
jamais avoir entendu parler de cette
façon de faire le historique pi2
comment télécharger comme kelly comme
calais si ce n'est les qualités vraiment
difficile tout à fait et coûte aux
changements aux mélanges mais je je fais
et faire ainsi toujours de choses
la méconnaissance et l'ignorance
pour moi la méconnaissance sait on
méconnaît c'est à dire on connaît pas
mais en une ouverture à apprendre
tandis que l'ignorance on s'enferme dans
l'ignorance
on s'enferme dans nos préjugés on
s'enferme dans nos a priori sans
nécessairement vouloir en sortir
je ne sais pas c'est pas un une
différenciation académique ou quoi que
ce soit moi c'est comme ça que je vois
ça tu vois et donc pour ce que tu dis
aime tant qu'homme pour le bye bye et 7
cette méconnaissance là et affectivement
cette méconnaissance qui souvent couplé
par l'ignorance parce que contre l'as
comme ce qui va arriver
et là des gens des communautés noires
vont se lever pour écouter on trouve sa
fin c'est un problème puis qu'est-ce
qu'est ce qu'on veut dire non mais vous
comprenez pas le nommer ce pas
l'intention non mais c'est juste drôle
puis terry un peu puis est donc en vous
mêmes nous faisait plus rire de rien
mais c'est sa exact donc on veut nous
dire comment est ce qu'on devrait sentir
tu vois on veut nous nous dire comment
est ce qu'on devrait penser par rapport
à des dynamiques qui nous touche
particulièrement
c'est ça que je trouve justement à face
à nantes où ça c'est ça que je trouve
paternaliste et racistes comme ne pas le
on tombe dans une hiérarchie du ressenti
c'est à dire ton ressenti ne vaut pas le
mien parce que moi j'ai décidé que ça te
français pas c'est que ça devrait pas de
français tous les jeudis et donc pour ça
que ces histoires de black fisc qui
reviennent d'année en année le bon je
sais pas s'il va en avoir d'autres
je crois que c'est long ces dernières
années il avait eu plusieurs
écoutez ce dernier encore le sait déjà
qu'ils ont juste décidé qu'ils ne
voulaient pas à prendre mais tu vois
quelqu'un une vieille photo de quelqu'un
qui a fait preuve le 25 ans je me dis
j'ose espérer qu'ils a appris depuis
mais si ça arrivait demain matin encore
une nouvelle occasion le tpiy pour pour
la sortie du passé le frère qui est
vraiment des gens qui vivent soit en
tout une roche ou qui veulent juste pour
voir le vent de vérité tout à fait
écoute même cette histoire de avec
justin trudeau en particulier quand
c'est sorti 25 ans plus tard c'est dans
un contexte électoral les élections plus
aux verts voulaient s'informer sur cette
photo là
puis longtemps dans sa poche en
attendant exactement je veux dire cette
journée là quand c'est sorti je pense
que j'ai refusé 14 entrevue j'ai compté
il ya 14 médias qui m'ont écrit pour
pouvoir faire une autre vue j'ai refusé
à chaque fois parce que je disais c'est
une magouille ou pas magouille message
stratagème électorale pour lui nuire
puis c'était en dehors la du du contexte
électoral bas les gens ça passerait fui
y apparaît pas mince et ça c'est comme
si à chaque fois que ça arrive on s'en
fout mais là puisque c'est dans un
contexte électoral tout d'un coup tout
le monde était jusque est fâché comme
c'est quoi laisser faire vous entrevue
arrangez-vous par vous-même puis si vous
voulez en parler de black fait on en
parlera après les élections m vu qu'on
n'en est jamais repartie c'est la
dernière fois qu'on a parlé séparément à
tout le monde en parle dès qu'un que
justin trudeau italie ben c'est ça et
puis juste et je dis ce sont des faits
historiques comme comme je disais un peu
plus tôt puis c'est des choses qui
méritent d'être d'être mentionné aussi
mais bon écoute à chacun ses intérêts
quand ils veulent et les maîtres de
laval puisque c'est ce qui se passe dans
dans les médias comment est ce que tu te
sens avec le fait que ça prend soin une
tragédie où des événements comme ceux
pour quelques le téléphone sonne au
temps comme ce que je dis pas ce qu'est
l'histoire des noirs devra parler
didier on doit avoir une occasion de re
pas avoir besoin d'un prétexte pour en
parler
si on fait partie de ce métier
nous on s'est dit ici à ce moment il ta
vie quelque chose de répit il se passe
quelque chose pis on peut pas ne pas en
parler ici ce serait se mettre la tête
dans sa donc aussi bien en parler avec
quelqu'un qui est première m'a informé
deuxièmement aussi premièrement touchés
par ces problématiques l'une sec mais
comme un contre sens qu'ils esquissent
ce qui était un sentiment comme doux
amer envers ceux où ben oui parce que je
faisais cette histoire là est encore un
peu relégués au rang d'anecdote si on
veut c'est à dire que c'est une histoire
qu'on ressort quand justement il ya de
la négativité qui se passe mais on
oublie que c'est fait partie de
l'histoire québécoise et canadienne on
s'est toujours histoire noire
c'est notre histoire collective à tout
le monde cette histoire n existe pas
à elle-même un silo et donc oui je
trouve ça plate que chaque fois qu'on
décide d'en parler ben c'est quand il
quelque chose de négatif et en
l'occurrence ici on parle d'une personne
qui a perdu sa vie plus d'une personne
lui donne emerson depuis longtemps
depuis plusieurs années exactement
et donc oui je trouve cela frustrant
surtout que tout d'un coup les gens
décident de s'arrêter au racisme pid
tout d'un coup tu décides d'être
offusqué du racisme entend mieux que les
gens s'offusquent mais imaginez-vous ça
prend des pertes de vie que les gens
décident de s'y arrêter quand justement
sont fait arrêter plus tôt on n'en
serait sûrement passé perte de ville
j'ai l'impression que que cette mort là
cette tragédie là j'ai espoir j'ai
l'impression que c'était celle de trous
malheureusement ces piquets qu'on est au
début d'un mouvement un peu comme un
mouvement qui est là pour durer et qui
va aurait des vrais changements qui vont
être là pour essayer j'ai passé deux
sens mais il me semble que justement des
histoires de de deux meurtres comme ceux
ci malheureusement pour le 1er mai est
ce que tu ressens quelque chose de
différent cette fois-ci par rapport
donne à fond
je sais pas j'aimerais ça j'aimerais ça
que plus réfléchir en tant que société
assez dynamique là je voudrais que j'ai
pas envie de trop m'avoir s'est
rapidement lahoud est retourné les trois
maires des sports danseurs exactement
parce que je dirais les souvent les gens
vont se
vont être fâchés les gens vont
s'offusquer puis deux semaines trois
semaines un mois plus tard sa part sans
que les craquelins ça disparaît et et
puis j'ai eu zéro voix au nombre de
personnes qui sont mortes chez venmar
ten a été tué il ya eu beaucoup de
mobilisation puis on en est où on en est
là aujourd'hui mais exactement est donc
des gens meurent joseph kata mairesse a
été tué son enfant un enfant qui a été
tués portant de mobilisation que ça non
plus ou du moins c'est pas rester plus
longtemps et donc là est ce que c'était
la fois de trop qui fait que ça va
passer à autre chose
espérons le mais je pense qu'il faut pas
non plus sous-estimer le temps le temps
avoir de l'oubli exactement faut pas
sous-estimer la commande sur la
stupidité des gens aussi était il faut
pas sous-estimer la mauvaise foi aussi
parce que faut comprendre que ce sont
des dynamiques où il ya des gens avec du
pouvoir les gens qui sont racistes jeudi
dans le chapiteau est à la présidence
des états unis dans notre homme qui est
un raciste qui a fait ces élections sous
sur une plateforme racistes à moitié
vous allez même pas principaux facteurs
de misogynie de sexisme le racisme et
est élu je faisais rien des gens que ça
arrange
il ya des gens qui sont à l'aise avec
ces dynamiques les trois cantons
elle parle de mecs america grille de
gaines basse et revenir aux années 50
des etats-unis où est ce que les noirs
étaient dans les ghettos qui avait pas
le droit de voter parce que les femmes
étaient dans les cuisines puis les
homosexuels étaient dans le dans le gard
d'europe et donc pour moi comme ça que
j'entends quand j'entends mais le cadre
et le guen c'est cette espèce de vision
d'un
quand on dit comme on dit de gourdonnais
de passer doré que jamais existé
finalement quelle époque
à quelle époque c'était référence parce
que moi j'avoue j'en vois aucune qui est
meilleur c'est vraiment lui c'est
carrément revenons avant que
avant qu'un noir en présidence pendant
huit ans oui parlement que c'est ce qui
sous-entend du dans son mec america do
it again pascalou la mairie que jamais
été aussi grecques les tissus parce qu'
il faut pas oublier que dans notre shop
existe parce que barack obama ouais je
dire dans notre chambre et une réaction
d'une certaine partie des états unis qui
ont été choqués de voir un noir à la
présidence et je dire tout c'est ce
mouvement dès qu'on appelle des beurs
furs ça devrait les gens qui disaient
que barack obama était pas né aux états
unis qui étaient menés au kenya jeudi
son intention mais oui c'est ça ce sont
des réactions racistes au final puis à
dans notre genre pas été un des fers de
lance de ce mouvement là aussi et donc
il faut pas sous-estimer le racisme et
surtout faut pas sous-estimer le racisme
systémique humain tu vois des choses on
a tellement de la difficulté à parler
parce que les gens pensent que quand on
dit racisme système et qu'on vous dit
racisme systématique
j'aime pas la même chose mais il faut en
parler je dis regarde il regarde la
pyramide sociale
si tu prends d'un point de vue
économique plus te montre le pyramid
plus est blanchi j'ai dit si tu regardes
dans tous les
dans tous les domaines il ya des
problèmes en terme d'emploi en termes de
logement en termes d'éducation en termes
de santé de vue au niveau de la culture
au niveau des sports regarder juste les
sports je prends basket football et ça
je parle des états unis mais je parle d'
ici aussi un jeu rapide dans tout le
monde occidental mais prenons là le
sport basket football baseball
la plupart des joueurs sont quelques
couleurs la plupart des managers et plus
du monde d honneur des propriétaires
encore aucun propriétaire qui noie oui
ou pas beaucoup à bout 6 1 assez de
bruit peu tu vois et donc la richesse
aux états unis dans le monde occidental
et bébé est mal distribuées et ça ça
revient de l' esclavage
ça vient de ce moment là parce que
esclave comment est-ce que tu va
acquérir du patrimoine soit c'était cela
petit pas acheter le pain terre que tu
allais gâté enfants qui vont léguer à
leurs enfants qu'ils peuvent revendre
faire de l'argent en achetant un autre
et c'est comme ça que se construit un
patrimoine sur les longues années sur
des décennies les décennies single
double décennie
on est loin en termes de disparités
sociales c'est pas un abri sans
l'exclavage qu'il est problématique
c'est avec journal mais les disparités
restent pas exactement puisque on dit
souvent c'est que l'esclavagé disparaît
mais les mentalités qui permettait l
esclavage demeure et donc si on regarde
dans le cadre des états unis de l
esclavage me dise lavage on passe à la
ségrégation et même si on parle jeu sans
parler de patrimoine les années 1930
30-40 le gouvernement américain a mis
sur pied des associations pour aider les
gens à acquérir des propriétés et a été
stimulée qu' il n'y avait pas de dette
qui pouvait être donnée aux personnes
noires toi donc on fait pas amener des
personnes noires dans certains quartiers
on ne peut pas les aider à acquérir des
propriétés donc encore de la législation
oui donc toi quatre-vingt dix ans 80 ans
après l'abolition de l'esclavagé
les gens ont encore de la difficulté à
acquérir un patrimoine et donc ces
disparités leur garde et même si on fait
juste un calcul rapide
on pense aux états unis on peut passer
au resto 6 mai aux états unis les
premiers esclaves dans la colonie
britannique arrive en 1619 l'esclavagé
dure jusqu'en 1865
donc on parle d'un 250 ans ou dont un
quart d'heure c'est ça après ça on tombe
la ségrégation 1865 au moins jusqu'à
1965 donc on parle de siècle de
ségrégation et donc 1965 a maintenant il
nous reste 90 enfants cinquantaine
d'années soit 155 soir et donc qu'ils
sont bons mais dans la balance la 240 en
esclavage 250 en esclavage sentant 2
de ségrégation qu'on était à 1 350 360
vers ce sont 60 puis ça je veux dire ça
en plus ce calcul c'est si tout allait
bien à partir des cinq dernières années
il n'y avait pas le cas toi et donc un
énorme disparité et ce sont ces
disparités à laquelle auxquels il faut
s'attaquer
on parle des états unis l'on peut parler
du canada - tout à fait on peut parler
de la présence autochtone aussi tu vois
une présence qui est ici depuis des
millénaires mais où est-ce qu'on
retrouve dans les gouvernements
provinciaux et fédéraux ou est-ce qu'on
retrouve les grandes compagnies et ses
rangs où est-ce qu'on retrouve en tant
que prof d'université et twitter je dire
sera system système et qui s'applique
ici aux personnes autochtones mais aussi
aux personnes assises et parce que le
canada aussi j'en parle un peu plus tard
la colonisation
d'un point de vue raciste mais aussi par
la suite ou 26 ans et qui avait des lois
contre l'immigration les personnes
noires et des lois contre l'immigration
des personnes asiatiques et donc on
voulait une immigration spécifiquement
blanche européenne et donc ce sont des
dynamiques qui nous a fait ici aussi au
canada mais c'est tellement plus
réconfortant de voir ce qui se passe aux
etats unis
regardez c'est plus apparent à les
etats-unis' toujours plus gros toujours
plus fous mais ce sont des dynamiques
qui nous affectent ici au québec et au
canada
ici ces masques et puis justement tu es
je pense que justement cette définition
du racisme ou sept
c'est le concept des racistes systémique
je pense que c'est qu'il est fondamental
à comprendre ce team exemple mots quand
j'étais jeune mes parents mes profs ou
pas aux primaires il faut pas être
raciste peut être à 6,6 mettons souvent
insulter la personne noire où tu vaux
ccdh grossier tu sais vraiment les actes
visibles facile à reconnaître
- pis du moment que c'est possible ça
bouge pas raciste je sais pas ce que
c'est tellement plus subtile pied
insidieux phi phi comme je commence à
apparaître entre le péage pythie le
racisme touche pas faut pas non c'est
pas non plus tu t'es où t'es pas au
racisme c'est tout un espèce de
gradation
qui est tellement de fois ces dames est
conscient de fois ci c'est justement tu
es toi personnellement et pour assister
au jour le jour avec les gens autour de
toi mais tu peux participer à un système
où qui permet ces injustices leurs ping
c'est ce qu'il faut questionner puis
ceux qui imaginent plus difficiles à
démanteler
c'est ce que tu ais je passe on est
beaucoup en tant que personnes blanches
à se poser la question qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire c'est quoi si où notre rôle
là dedans je pense que un des premiers
rôles cessé de réfléchir c'est d'écouter
ccc l'abside et d'apprendre sur le sujet
puis connaître sa place là dedans puis
après ça comment qu'on peut faire un
changement sans tomber non plus dans le
complexe du duo assez vieux ou du saas
en devenait paternaliste quoi que ce
soit si très délicate stress et le pij
est pas encore trouvé la réponse à ces
questions en direct
ben si tu trouves je pense qu'il ya bien
des gens qui ont des situations qui sont
puisqu'ils sont difficiles qui sont
compliqués je pense que de reconnaître
déjà ses privilèges là c'est une chose
c'est après c'est d'en parler
c'en est une autre de refuser aussi le
racisme autour des usa comme une fois
puis je me complais d'attentats une joke
racisme était comme c'était juste passé
était à un islamophobe x y tenons je
pense que il faut agir comme ça et
mettre des pressions aussi sommes-nous
gouvernement sur nos organes de presse
de télé et cetera pour qu'une plus
grande représentativité mais pas
seulement à l'écran parce que ça revient
à voir des sportifs noirs sur le sol
vidéo ne blanc exactions et donc de
mettre des pressions pour que la
hiérarchie aussi sera season guillemets
tech on est des que ce soit des
réalisateurs des directeurs xy qui
proviennent de ces communautés là parce
qu'on parle des afrodescendants ce mais
j'ai zéro on peut parler d'un autochtone
au système autant de présences
asiatiques et arabes
sinon et c'est à dire
renversement par pratiquement totale de
ce qui se passe en ce moment là comment
des sucres au renversement du statu quo
parce que le statu quo profitent
toujours à quelqu'un exactement et
profitent toujours à quelqu'un si un
imprimé kenya préfète aussi exactement
appui ce qui est particulier c'est que
on en profite parfois sans même s'en
douter ou sans même vouloir y penser ils
visaient les vêtements comporte la les
vêtements comporte qui sont fabriqués
dans des noms des sweatshops c'est
facile de penser de passer à d'autres
choses mais tes pantalons continue son
chemin mais c'est une réalité aussi et
je disais c'est facile de l'oublier puis
de passer à d'autres choses puis je mets
plus la borne tout à fait
et donc il faut prendre conscience de
ces différentes dynamiques là puis à gm
et c'est une action qui doit être fait
au jour le jour où en est exactement qui
demande énormément de réflexion à chaque
petite action qu est ce que je lisais
sur twitter une conversation en deux
économistes qui disait que eux se
sentait les économistes et étaient
toutes là les gens qui gère l'économie
qui sentait au centre de cette
conversation le dire que c'était aussi
un problème économique de classe sociale
qui gruge qui creusait des fossé énorme
entre les classes puis qui justement
séparer les différentes ethnies dans
certains secteurs qui créent une tension
comme ceux entre les classes comme
comment on sort de ce wpt une question à
qui bon bah qui vont au prix nobel en
économie
mais oui quelles sont les pistes et en
tant que société pour dire ça peut pas
continuer comme cela
je pense qu'effectivement c'est un
problème économique ce problème de
capitalisme je pense que c'est un
problème de consommation débridée au aux
dépens de d'autres de d'autres
populations et faut pas oublier que je
reviens à l esclavage souvent parce que
pour moi c'est là le point d'ancrage de
nos sociétés aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que j'ai fait un long détour historique
mots du maire je suis fasciné mais c'est
de l'économie c'est à dire que avant la
la traite transatlantique ça doivent
aller chercher des africains pour les
amener en esclavage dans les amériques
l'économie de l'europe était
sensiblement la même que un peu partout
ce à dire qu'en amérique que chez les
autochtones ou les africains c'est à
dire les terres agricoles
les échanges étaient donc on avait la
grille culture les échanges etc
donc ya pas de méga plantations en
europe à partir du moment où ce qu'on a
pris des africains qu'on a placé sur la
terre des autochtones et qu'on a
développé toutes ces terres là en méga
plantations pour faire du sucre 1 pour
faire de l'indigo pour faire la teinture
bleus pour faire le scoop dont le tabac
le cacao
eh bien ça propulsé l'europe
tout l'argent l'or et l'argent qui
venait des mandats mais du sud vers
l'espagne
tous ces ressources premières qu'on
amenait des élastiques guadeloupe
bahamas et chirac ont amené vers
l'angleterre qu'on a mené vers la france
qui contribuait à une grande partie de
l'économie et ces marchés-là de ses
colonies étaient des marchés captifs
c'est à dire que la colonie au poche
choix d'acheter ces produits finis de la
métropole donc admettons t en nouvelle
france du bas rhin serment à acheter
des choses autre part qu'en france et tu
peux pas revendre dans matières
premières autre part qu'en france au
rythme où la france le voeu que ça c'est
pour tout le tout les lélés les colonies
ce qui a poussé entre autres les treize
colonies à se rebeller toi et qui est
devenu les états unis parce que les
redevances aussi été exorbitant
oui c'est ça la métropole s'arrange
comme un peu parce que l'importance de
nourrir la métropole la colonie sert à
nourrir
économiquement la métropole et donc on a
une amérique qui est un marché captif de
l'europe en afrique dans la force
humaine et ponctionner pour cultiver ces
matières là et donc ça propulsé l'europe
économiquement et technologiquement
aussi
et toi à ce moment là les européens
voulaient changer avec la chine le japon
et ses erreurs mais voulait rien savoir
parce que les européens n'avaient rien
qui intéressait la chine et le japon
et donc c'est l'esclavagé cetera
ces pillages des ressources a permis une
avancée technologique qui une fois
arrivés en chine une fois arrivé au
japon juste eu à forcer militairement
ces marchés là pour échanger toi et donc
même toute cette histoire là du monde
atlantique une incidence jusqu'à nazis
se voit jusqu'à jusqu'à là jusqu'à la
chine jusqu'au japon
et donc cette prééminence occidentale
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle a les deux
pieds trempés dans l'esclavagé des 500
dernières années et ça on peut pas le
l'extirper de ça parce que sinon c'est
encore une vision très eurocentrée des
bambins l'europe de par son génie s'est
hissé au dessus des autres comme de
nulle part toi mais quand on analyse on
se rend compte que c'est son appui sur
la tête des africains des autochtones
qui a le l'europe pu jouer ce rôle dans
l'est
les derniers siècles et donc c'est pour
ça que quand on parle de brutalités
policières quand on parle de privilèges
quand on parle tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment pour moi doit automatiquement
le ramener à l'histoire des 500
dernières années mais christophe colomb
cc c'est fascinant ça permet de mieux
comprendre d'où on 12 ça vient ce qui
nous amène à maintenant nous amène à
aujourd'hui
ce qui nous amène aux problématiques du
moment c'est à dire une en direction
d'une guerre civile j'imagine aussi
états unis prochainement ça continue à
escalader à ce rythme-là m'écoute je
sais pas en guerre civile
est-ce que chez surtout c'est que les
gens qui veulent une guerre civile sont
les gens de la l'espèce d'extrême droite
qu'on appelle au cra est aussi qui a qui
veulent une deuxième guerre civile et ça
c'est des gens racistes lourdement armés
je pense pas que ce soit les les
instruments les afro-américains harlem
qui se disent on veut une autre guerre
civile je ne faut pas oublier que la
guerre civile
un méfait à l' esclavage et donc je
pense que les gens qui veulent une
guerre civile aux états unis sont cette
frange qui hantent route votre
programmation de le conserver leurs
armes et qu'ils envoient leurs
privilèges
exactement et donc écouter ce que ça se
dirige vers une guerre civile ou pas je
sais pas mais je dire tu m'aurais ce
mardi 6 mois qu'irène méga pandémie qui
va carteret
le flot de la planète pendant plusieurs
mois j'ai coach est était toujours lundi
leur écoute
tout est possible si je c'est important
aussi dans des situations comme ceux de
départager les gens qui sont là pour une
réelle manifestation puis les gens qui
sont là aussi pour causer du grabuge
avec un agenda de cépie juste à québec
hier lé la manifestation qui a eu
étaient pacifiques montréal
ouais avec montréal la même façon qu'il
ya montréal étaient pacifiques étaient
étaient dans l'ordre était super bien
fait pis on dirait que tu veux toujours
avoir quelqu'un qui va arriver le
profiter de la situation qui a beaucoup
de gens dans les rues pour casser
quelque chose pour faire quelque chose
dans le but pro taille de discréditer le
mouvement ou dans le bus juste qui est
des gens qui ont un espèce de besoins
étrange de cause les choses ou de jus de
profiter le genre de pas de ko mais du
fait que beaucoup de gens dans les rues
pour sa perméabilité de toute toute
représaille way coûte le grabuge je
pense pour faire attention avant de
juger complètement toi martin luther
king martin luther king l'icône du
pacifisme avec gandhi martin luther king
dit les émeutes sont le langage des gens
qui n'écoutent pas
l'un god of the hundred tracy les gens
manifestent de manière pacifique à
chaque fois qu'apple nick qui mangent
nos partenaires quand c'est l'hymne
national vu ce qui s'est passé la job
soit les gens par la mettons reçoivent
un prix et prennent position puis tout
d'un coup ils seront fustigé les gens
marchent dans la rue vide à un moment
donné les pressions que s'est nourri
tout simplement le statu quo
tu vois et c'est frédéric dalle est un
ancien esclave s'est enfui qui devenu un
leader abolitionniste aux états unis
qu'ils disaient
rébellion mais on peut voir ici le
grabuge me dis qu'est ce qui est pire
le grabuge où les causes du grabuge et
donc souvent quand on voit que je trouve
sur cette question du grabuge j'ai
l'impression que encore une fois on fait
passer la propriété à voir la vie
humaine
tu vois et surtout quand on s'adresse à
une adresse la situation à propos de
personnes qui étaient eux mêmes traités
comme de la propriété c'est des gens qui
pendant des siècles étaient des
propriétés et là tout d'un coup on va
dire bon vin coûte la propriété vaut
plus que ta vie tu vois est donc simple
pour moi le grabuge qui comprend la
frustration c'est à dire que ces
symboles d'une frustration amer toi et
tu vois je la condamne pas dit je la
comprends je la comprends la colère puis
justement là la manifestation pacifique
à l'est était fait clairement le pas eu
l'effet escompté non plus donc je
comprends tout à fait qui c'est au
québec qu'on est une révolution
tranquille mais c'est vraiment pas
toutes les révolutions qu'ils se font
attaquer le mal pipi c'est normal mais
ce que je voulais aussi dire c'est que
parfois il ya carrément des gens qui
sont là pour tgv vu des vidéos ou que
les manifestations où il carrément
dirigeant d'extrême droite qui vont là
qui pousse les personnes les
afro-américains va sur les policiers
pour cris des affrontements des facs et
oui ça c'est coach tout à fait d'accord
et des gens qui utilisent ces prétextes
là effectivement tu es mais pour ça je
pense faut toujours voir un peu avoir
une certaine distance souci par rapport
à ça j'ai vu une vidéo pour possiblement
vous l'avez vu c'est un homme plus âgé
un homme noir plus âgés qui parle
un homme dont je pense qu'il ya peu près
une cinquantaine d'années après ce temps
un homme d'une trentaine d'années les
deux les deux s'obstine mais vraiment
dans un genre de on sent que les deux
ont beaucoup d'émotion mais qui se
respecte malgré tout puis la personne
l'homme plus âgés ils prendre des
actions plus violentes
puis le plus jeune dit c'est pas comme
ça que ça va passer c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va réussir à faire passer notre
message c'est de la phase i de cette
façon là qui vont discréditer le
mouvement puis la personne le gueut plus
âgées dit le les autres façons
fonctionne pas edit je les fais ici j'ai
déjà eu tendance que je dise ça
fonctionne pas puis le plus jeune a
amené il fait venir un autre gars qui
est une génération encore en dessous qui
comme 12 à 15 ans puis il dit en est
votre âme au sommet dans mes souliers à
moins mais dis moi j'ai une petite fille
de deux ans pis je veux pas qu'elle ait
besoin d'en venir à la violence
chloé creepy faut trouver une autre
façon mais en faisant ça savoie casse
parce que clairement ayant n'est pas la
solution c'est pile celui plus vieux qui
vit seule depuis des années qui lui vu
sa vue des comme tu disais tout à
l'heure tu sais c'est déjà arrivé que
des démonter quand il ya eu un événement
cible et puis qui rien ne s'est passé
que rien ne s'est passé depuis ce lundi
là on est rendu
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand que rien
qu'on peut faire
j'ai l'impression que c'est ces seuls en
ce moment oui puis faut pas oublier que
c'est une histoire violente
oui je veux dire c'est une histoire
violente les états unis sont cons c'est
un pays qui s'est construite dans la
violence perpétuelle et jeudi ce sont
des violences qui sont subit aussi
et toi c'est drôle parce que si on
regarde l'histoire survie est toujours à
l'histoire s'est pressée c'est la façon
qu'on prend les gens vont porter aux
nues la révolution américaine
tu vois quand ils sont libérés
violemment du groupe britannique
on va on va mettre son piédestal et
révolution française
des gens qui sont opposés violemment à
la monarchie avec des milliers de morts
on va célébrer la révolution haïtienne
déjà qu'ils se sont battus violemment
pour contrer cette violence qui l
esclavage et donc la violence
fait partie de ce cadre là mais elle est
rebaptisée on la trouve cool quand ça
fait des siècles futurs arrive
maintenant c'est plus courtois mais on
va célébrer les gens qui l'ont fait
avant depuis même à l'époque de la
révolution américaine
les premiers qui les les premiers
échaffourées comme on pense aux
massacres de boston 775 je me souviens
plus bas à l'ailé quand on va en parler
dans les médias
les gens vont bondir bon vous voyez si
une bande de voyous
tu vois ce sont des des casseurs qui ont
qui qui veulent aller contre l'ordre
établi et donc on a le même discours
qu'on a ces gens avaient le même
discours à l'époque qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui envers les jeunes qui à le
faire de manière un peu plus tough
démontre aussi que l'histoire est
toujours à compter avec lui avec la
lunette avec l'oeil de celui qui la
raconte qu'il équipe qui agonise ont vu
son combat tout à fait tout à fait parce
qu'une révolution qui serait équipe qui
mouraient dans l'oeuf
on dirait justement c'était des cancers
des voyous de tout à fait puis je dire
comme on dit le squale expression on dit
le révolutionnaire 2 1 et le terroriste
de l'autre toit où le combattant de la
liberté 2 1 et le terroriste de l'autre
se voit donc parfois c'est le même s'il
avait lui-même la même pièce où
exactement il sait quand on parle de
brutalité policière de profilage racial
en ce moment notre regard est tourné
vers les états unis
évidemment on vit paulo évidemment on
n'y a pas de compton
au québec qui a morial ce qu'elles sont
pour pour 2 go blanc qu'elle quels sont
les enjeux raciale
ici au québec actuellement en 2020 mais
regarde on est 3 qui avons grandi à
québec
1 comme une fois de ce fait intercepter
par la police pour redonner ton
identitaire au froid jamais bon ben je
me suis fait intercepter pour vous deux
ça se compte en plusieurs dizaines de
fois ah ouais oh oui j'exagère mais paul
j'ai arrêté de compter un moment donné
ça m'est déjà arrivé deux fois dans la
même journée trois fois en deux jours
pour aucune règle aucune raison trois
fois en deux jours c'est d'ailleurs une
journée que ces deux fois le matin et le
soir
le matin en allant travailler j'en avais
travaillé à 8 heures du matin je me fais
collet je sors de chez nous je me fais
que les chefs des amis je me fais que
les jeux d'hier c'est une réalité qu'on
ne connaît que trop tu vois et je pense
qu'on a eu l'image reste quand même
autour de cette table est donc le
profilage racial est une réalité bien
vivante à québec à montréal aussi 0 le
spvm avait commandé une étude sur le
profilage racial qui est sorti l'automne
passé n'était pas très content de la non
c'était pas très très content puis je
pense l'époque québec devrait en faire
eux mêmes oui je pense que oui mais on
connaît déjà je peux vous l'écrire si
vous voulez ces jeux d'hier même cet été
il y avait cet homme qui un homme noir
qui est une compagnie qui l'avait les
restos la nuit besoin compagnie
ménagères de travaux ménagers et lui se
passait de place en place pour gérer ses
équipes la nuit en vélo dans ces rock
il se faisait que les pratiquement
chaque soir que se fait la nuit mais je
travaille travaille ou qu'est ce que tu
fais donc il ya sept
cette manière d'un de nos forces de
l'ordre de devoir et d'évaluer les gens
à travers des lunettes raciste qui
viennent de deux de ces époques là c'est
à dire que c'est moi delà de la noce
citoyenneté en guillemets du noir c'est
à dire que tu es un noir la nuit que tu
fais là ne pas se poser d'être là tu es
dans tel quartier des pas se poser dans
tel quartier mais c'était dans ton
quartier caisse
feller dans ton quartier j'ai à
cap-rouge me fait coller mais je vais à
limoilou je me fais collet et donc pour
pour ma part c'est la deuxième fois que
service en 2016 ce qui fait préciser
quand ces récentes et puis encore ça
marche ça m'arrive - parce que ils me
reconnaissent maintenant tu es mais je
le vois qu'ils sont sur le bord il
continue des fois j'avoue à la main et
me me reconnaissent pas qu'ils savent
très bien mais je pense aux jeunes qui
n'ont pas le privilège que j'ai un peu
plus sur la place publique
et eux le vivent ils le vivent que je
disais on l'a vu c'est des choses qui
arrivent à repentigny aussi qui arrivent
asher book qui arrive à ottawa qui
arrive à toronto
ça arrive partout ça arrive partout puis
on ne peut pas encore ouvert le dossier
de la france
je lisais hier justement l'article de
radio canada sur les rapports dont tu
parles c'est qui qui disait clairement
que c'était une personne noire arabe ou
autochtone à montréal le vérificateur à
4,5 fois plus de chances de faire
d'autre part intercepté tipi il y avait
un petit vidéo avec la réaction du
chemin du chef de police de montréal
pays dits dit je crois pas que des
policiers racistes à montréal dit je
crois que les policiers sont des
citoyens puis automatiquement et se
disent tous les citoyens ont parfois des
billets jetés comme c'est exactement la
même chose s'il vient de décrire les
racismes on est tellement on dirait que
notamment pas de ce mot l'appui
évidemment pas se faire coller
l'étiquette qui n'arrange pas raciste
j'ai juste des billets mais douceur
racisme exacte des fois tu le fais
concernant les foi se fait de manière
inconsciente mais les allées de existe
peu tu es un policier tu peux coller
quelqu'un passait juste au noir c'est
sûr que ou tu peux le faire sans tarder
recompte fine art scène j'avais des je
pense qu'on a beaucoup de travail à
faire en tant que société et pour moi ce
qui est dangereux c'est toujours de se
comparer à tu vois comment met-on j'ai
donné beaucoup d'entrevues à choix radio
x games - p
telle place où c'est moins pire at-elle
place mais ce que je leur disais c'est
que c'est comparer finalement ce move de
paresseux ouais c'est à dire à ce cours
ici c'est moins pire qu'aux états unis
facteurs mais on a réussi ont conféré
ainsi en cause la tendance les
conversations de parler qu'est-ce qu'il
fait pendant de ce qui se passe ici
mission d'améliorer ce qu'ont permis à
rhys hill
même si et riot pas exactement je veux
que ce soit pire ou mieux ailleurs
ça nous concerne pas ce qu'il faut c'est
nous mêmes par rapport à nous mêmes
est-ce qu'on veut que tout le monde ait
les mêmes chances et ce qu'on veut que
tout le monde puisse avoir accès aux
mêmes types d'éducation au même type
d'emploi est ce que quelqu'un qui va
apporter son cv ou son nom c'est mohamed
versus guy puis que guy risque d'être
plus engagé que moi remède mais qui
pourtant est autant qu'elle fier ou plus
qualifiés dépendamment je dire ça
demeure un problème
ce soit encore une fois à montréal à
québec ou ailleurs au québec et est pour
moi et toi je le disais cet hiver pour
la commémoration du l'attentât
terroriste à la mosquée de québec y
avait une commémoration et c'est ça que
je disais aux gens je veux j'ai pris la
parole puis je disais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a si peur de parler de racisme ici
pourquoi ce qu'on a si peur de parler de
ces questions là parce que pourtant on
est capable de parler de sexisme du
sexisme au québec
oui mais ça fait des serments de nous
déjà sexistes au monde
est-ce que l'homophobie au québec est
sûr que déjà homophobes
est ce que ça fait de nous des
homophobes les québécois tout dire mais
dès qu'on parle de racisme il ya du
racisme au québec que deux tu dis que
tout le monde est raciste était et donc
c'est simple je comprends pas pourquoi
ce qu'on n'est pas capable de parler de
racisme pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est pas
capable de parler de moteurs de
d'islamophobie
quand c'est zoé semi phobie là on est
capable de mettre sur la table puis d'en
résulter de manière sérieuse et mature
dit avoir écouté oui et des problèmes et
comment est-ce qu'on peut s'attaquer à
ces problèmes là mais ça n'est pas
capable de nommer le problème comment
est ce que tu racontes con qu'on
s'attaque au problème si on
on le nomme pas je poserai forcément je
peu de réponses c'est là c'est là que
c'est là qu'on a menée c'est là qu'on en
ait en tant que société c'est en ce
moment on voit des j'imagine des
balbutiements d'un espèce des sorts
médias sociaux de deux dvi j'imagine
non bon pour en parler pour voir pour
parler de tout ça en fait mais c'est
comment dire clairement on a un problème
clair monsieur c'est indéniable
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais tu vois déjà
en ce moment avec ce qui se passe en ce
moment j'ai l'impression que les gens
sont écoeurés aussi s'est exposé les
noirs qui sont écoeurés je pense que les
blancs aussi tout le monde est écoeuré
de voir ça mais comme on disait tantôt
l'essentiel c'est de l'établir dans le
temps ouais c'est à dire de l'établir de
manière soutenue on est contre et
quelles sont nos solutions et appliquons
l'est mais l'appliquons de la longévité
ça c'est rien donné un boost vite passer
à autre chose et moi c'est ça qui
m'inquiète un peu haut qui me décourage
à l'époque des réseaux sociaux
ouais c'est à dire que les réseaux
sociaux là on a un côté 1 extrêmement
négatif
oui hawks côté positif de mobilisation
tu peux voir on va éclater le plan
assouté et moins mobilisé de faire
circuler les idées mais il ya un moyen
de taux gratification d'auto
satisfaction à ses pas c'est à dire bon
mais quand j'ai mis mon poste black
light bearer aujourd'hui où j'ai mis mon
poste solidarité à georges floyd puis si
on le voit en ce moment comme ça y est
j'ai j'ai contribué toi ça veut rien
dire tant que l'action se transpose pas
sur le terrain où est ce que les gens
vont prendre action
ça veut rien dire qui était posté un
truc en support le pour moi c'est
l'équivalent aux etats unis qu à chaque
fois que massacres de masse les gens
qu'est ce qu'ils disent
dans cette période brière a accentué pas
saisi prière ok on y goûte doigts et
donc je trouve que c'est cela le grand
inconvénient des réseaux sociaux où on
note autosatisfaction assez facilement
donc oui passe à nous d'avoir fait
quelque chose d'avoir l'impression
d'avoir fait quelques
puis on nous amène tête à parler d'un
concept qui a paru dans les derniers 48
72 heures qui est l'espèce de deux ont
mis en fait il ya peu sur le white gilt
fait de dire aux personnes blanches qui
font pas justement de repartager un
black light demandeurs de de repartager
d'entreprise avec john floyd ou c'est
ici en gardant en prenant silence ou en
apprenant porte parole devient complice
à la violence ça a été un trend qui a
été énorme
ça fait que tout le monde pratiquement
sur le dos sociaux j'imagine s'est
sentie alliés en partageant du story
sans probablement poussé la réflexion
nécessairement plus loin que de faire
sopi je pense que ce que te dis du
niveau de satisfaction personnelle
vraiment beau d'abord l'impression
d'avoir agi parce que te fais partie
d'un courant puis d'un mouvement propre
possiblement qu'une fois ayant fait ce
que tu es satisfait de ta propre
implication
tu arrêtes ton raisonnement à plus loin
que oui tout à fait puis tu vois moi je
suis pas intéressé par la culpabilité je
m'en fous pour moi ça me change et ce
qui m'importe c'est la responsabilité
tu vois c'est à dire que les gens
réalisent qu'ils ont aussi une
responsabilité par rapport à ça c'est
une responsabilité qui est commune des
dynamiques qui peuvent ne se régler que
collectivement
tu vois tu parles de le silence complice
quand on regarde
regardons plus petite échelle 1 qu'est
ce qui se passe dans l'église catholique
avec la pédophilie
qu'est ce qu'on dit les lélés les
prêtres tous acquis qui ne dénoncent pas
et son complice soit on regarde la
police audi ouais mais c'est pas tous
les policiers qui qui agissent comme ça
ouais mais tu as rien fait quand tu le
veux agir ou tu le peux dénoncé ilias
cette espèce de l'esprit de corps qui
fait qu' on se tient les coudes
quoi qu'il se passe et donc en société
je pense pas nécessairement à cet esprit
de corps là mais je pense qu'il ya un
certain silence complice it ou c'est une
question qui nous une question qui nous
touche tout le monde
c'est une question qui nous implique qui
que nous soyons en société de contribuer
à quelque chose de mieux
et donc c'est c'est pas c'est pas
anguille mais les noirs qui va régler le
problème des noirs toi c'est ici on
rapporta encore j'utilise beaucoup les
exemples de sexisme ou l'homophobie
c'est pas les femmes qui ont réglé le
problème des femmes
ce n'est pas les homosexuels qui vont
régler le problème des homosexuels c'est
tout le monde en société qui doit
changer ces mentalités pour changer la
manière dont on voit les femmes soient
au top
c'est notre manière de changer nos
mentalités face aux enjeux lgbt que plus
au racisme et si c'est tout le monde qui
doit se sentir concerné pour pouvoir
changer
est ce que parce que je veux dire c'est
tout le monde qui constituent la société
c'est aussi simple que ça c'est tous les
éléments doivent mettre la main à la
pâte
tu voyais t on a parlé un petit peu plus
tôt aujourd'hui puis justement depuis
ces événements là il voudrait pas un
moment et je veux dire depuis les
derniers jours ça que mon esprit parce
que j'étais ces images le sont horribles
pays puisqu'ils se pose en ce moment
c'est très important mais j'ai j'avais
un certain malaise
en allant dans les dix huit réseaux
sociaux puis donner mon grain de sel sur
la situation c'est parce que je pense
vraiment que ça doit être accompagnée
d'une profonde réflexion c'est parce que
je veux pas si moi j'ai une aussi belle
vie dans le sens ton pions et disputant
tôt s'était construit juste dire nos
privilèges on déconstruit sur
l'esclavagisme
ça a pris c'est important de savoir des
prêts à concéder peut-être une partie de
mes acquis ou je ne sais pas qui
exactement quoi faire mais on dirait
qu'elle de suite donné mon apprenti
évidemment quelque chose que je sais que
je suis profondément attristé par ce
mais je trouve ça un petit peu hypocrite
en autant de manières de juste partager
quelque chose ça qui a une profonde
remise en question que tout à fait
d'accord puis pour ma part les réseaux
sociaux sobriété pour ma part j'ai rien
partager sur les réseaux sociaux
la seule chose que j'ai partagé c'est la
manifestation à québec qui s'en vient 7
juin prochain mais je partage et aucune
vidéo qu'une pensée par rapport à ça
parce que les réseaux sociaux j'ai ce
sentiment là aussi que c'est beaucoup et
on parle de marcher marcher versus par
les nazis les gens parlent beaucoup mais
marche peu et donc pour ma part les
réseaux sociaux c'est l'équivalent de
parler beaucoup tu vois et donc je
respecte le fait que tu te dis ce que
j'ai besoin de le faire pour justement
je me sens la pression ne me dira voir
faut que je le fasse et ouais je pense
que le plus important de réfléchir à où
est ce que tu te situes et qu'est ce que
tu peux faire qu'est ce que tu peux
contribuer pour changer ces mentalités
là en tant que société puisque de tout
de suite appuyé sur partagez le mais
quand je voyais justement certaines
personnes poster quelque chose qui petit
voyait que c'était pas le partage mais
une réelle réflexion n'est en réalité
que personne ou une vidéo que brice de
parents quelqu'un fait je me dis ok ya
vraiment une recherche derrière ce
vraiment une réflexion l'on dirait que
je me dis ah il sentait à l'aise et moi
on dit que ma pensée n'était pas assez
pis je n'ai pas encore trouvé les mots
justes pour m'exprimer mais je respecte
sait aussi qu'il y trouve qu'ils font
avec est avec une justesse le south tout
à fait d'accord puis je dire j'ai l'air
de parler beaucoup cordes les réseaux
sociaux mais je voyais des gens qu'ils
utilisent à bon escient aussi et puis
qui sait déjà qu'il utilise pour
s'informer pour informer pour mobiliser
donc oui effectivement mais il ya
beaucoup de pareilles
trop site et puis qu'on le voit chaire
chose qui prend de l'ampleur
mettre beaucoup de gens aussi qui vont
juste vouloir greffer à ce exactement
la vague est ce que est ce que la
solution passe par la politique
oui et non c'est à dire que je pense que
la solution ne peut pas se limiter qu'à
une des seules ce faire ces sphères
politique économique académique aussi
social communautaire culturel toutes ses
sphères leçons importantes l'académique
geiser reprenons notre cas locale
est-ce que vous avez déjà appris une
histoire qui avait une présence
africaine ici depuis 1629 j'aime ce que
je t'ai déjà à la base notre manière de
voir notre histoire est fausse et jamais
qu'on a appris qu'avec d'esclavagé si
jamais qu'on a appris qu'à une présence
afrodescendantes depuis l'époque de
champlain pour l afrique et arrive
champlain est toujours vivant tu vois et
d'ailleurs les vielles le jeune qui n'a
par exemple quand on compare les
autochtones ou si tu lis on apprend en
plus on se souvient des maisons l'ont
plutôt monde se souvient des séries
passionnant on a parlé un petit peu
moins les côtés plus difficile et
l'histoire d'accord on n'ose pas trop en
parler c'est oui pis encore comment
l'histoire est faite c'est que les
autochtones sont seulement des figurants
de la voiture européenne ici désir pour
la plupart des gens l'histoire commence
en 1608
avant ça c'est un flou
et donc effectivement je dire la place
des autochtones et de voir l'histoire
comme une histoire coloniale géré même
encore récemment je parlais avec des
gens et puis je disais at il faut jamais
oublier que la colonisation c'est un
viol
toi et tu dis oui mais non mais oui mais
nous ici piges comme non non j'ai pas
demandé aux amérindiens comment ils sont
par rapport à ça la colonisation toi
mais c'est comme si lier la hiérarchie
des ressentis c'est presque comme si ça
va à l'époque autant que et donc notre
manière de nous enseigner l'histoire
très importante
après ça on a parlé de l'économie
politique aussi je pense que c'est
important d'avoir des personnes qui qui
qui qui prennent des décisions avoir
plus de personnes racisées aussi dans
l'appareil politique sans que ce soit
des taux kane ou six ans que ce mardi
bursa regarde amarin segun en en
hegoalde merci fit donc il ya aussi des
des toqués knees et là la politique tu
vois que ce soit au niveau des
ministères et à tous les tous les
niveaux hiérarchiques en culture même
chose que ce soit sur les planches en
dehors des planches devant la caméra
derrière la caméra
c'est la première fois que j'entends
l'expression token mais il ya de la
tokenisation aussi en culture mais
comment s'aimer se commet qu'on la
reconnaît cette organisation le sens que
c'est aujourd'hui on taille vite parce
qu'on va avoir une réelle discussion
avec toi tu es donc pas parce qu'on veut
vous réveiller tout le monde connaît des
bonnes personnes qu'elles sont restées
comprend way puis mais je suis certain
que ça existe mais on dirait que c'est
comme avec les réseaux sociaux tu sais
pas si le pose la personne est vraiment
authentique est accompagné d'une
réflexion ou non entrer que toi ce qui
est une manière de se différencier sur
ben écoute ça dépend des discours aussi
ça dépend du rôle qu'on donne à la
personne c'est la personne on la voit là
mais là aucun pouvoir
c'est un bon indicateur en position
décisionnel
mais que souvent on la voit là aussi
dans les discours qui sont portées ou
pas porter les choses qui sont dites ou
les choses qui ne sont pas les choses se
sont passées sous silence aussi donc il
ya plusieurs manières de le repérer
tout le monde n'est pas qu'un mais quand
on envoie en europe c'est facile à
précieux pour les organisations les
sommes non non non écouter on est
gothique et nos box noter qu'on apprend
on dispose pour être laissé certains
d'entre eux parfait et on est revenus
qui grillent moi je me pose une question
si on parlait dans tous préfèrent
raciale puis programme était juste et
l'article de radio canada que j'avais lu
py qui disait programmation par led
représente représentativité aussi qu
aimer ton il ya seulement 10 % des
policiers qui sont issus des minorités
ne tient ce qui vraiment de ceux des
mets ton la vraie représentativité dans
la population montréal donc c'est ce qui
s'en rendre des problèmes puis puis via
j'écoutais un témoignage de félix aujali
assume le jour le tennis c'est pire à
côté juste une anecdote c'est beau du
tout anodine meetic et des quelque chose
qui est arrivé à québec ne sont pas son
parti africain de se piquer au jeu se
promenait tranquillement dans son
quartier à l'ancienne lorette puisqu'il
s'est collé par par la police et puis
qu'est ce que vous faites là monsieur py
puis ben je m'envoie une pige conduit
mon auto c'est vichy la police yabassi
jeu c'est rare de voir des personnes
noires dans le quartier si conduire des
mercedes si on n'est pas trop habitué à
cette cible
c'est une anecdote qui illustre beaucoup
ticket mojorité un homme black conduit
une mercedez à l'ancienne lorette à
québec un petit coin tranquille jamais
il va se faire coller juste parce que
qui passe qui conduit dans son quartier
c'est fou pis tout moi je me demandais
toi qui as vécu que grandi à québec mais
que vécut longtemps québec maintenant
évidemment real est ce que parce que tu
es différent de ses perceptions québec
versus montréal parce que c'est ce que
c'est ce que ces pays parce que c'est
moins pire toi dans ton expérience est
ce qu'il ya une différence ou séparés
par tous non il ya des différences selon
les lieux les quartiers même jeu
derrière des différences à québec entre
les différents quartiers et je pense que
si tu faisais tu parlais de
représentativité en plus du nombre de
policiers issus des diversités en guinée
de en fait de personnes racisées est ce
que ça change quelque chose moi j'ai
toujours dit qu'il faudrait que la
police ait plus de personnes racisées à
québec parce qu'à ne pas mélanger 00 il
ya des des études aux états unis qui ont
montré que ça changeait pas grand chose
en terme de profilage racial mais moi
j'ai l'impression que ça change quelque
chose au niveau de la population
c'est à dire qu'une personne un citoyen
lambda se fait sauvé la vie en
guillemets par une personne racisées qui
policiers ou qui se fait donner une
contravention ou qui se fait il ya une
interaction par l'interaction connaître
la police une interaction qu'on a avec
la société est le bras armé de la
société et donc que admettons à québec
ce bras armé la soie tout blanc parle en
soit tu vois mais si des jeunes peuvent
se voir à la police si d'aider des
personnes planchent peut voir des
personnes assises et dans la police ça
permet d'avoir une vision différente de
l'autre en guillemets et donc je pense
que c'est important qu'ils en aient
est-ce que ça va régler le profilage
racial
je pense pas mais au moins ça pourra
contribuer et tu vois là comme la halle
la police hier que key qui arrête le
monsieur pas ce qui est en merco bien
d'avoir un collègue noir bat déjà ça va
peut-être les ducs est un peu juste
j'ai pensé que justement c'était des
collègues et confrères consorts des
différentes cultures
ça c'est une première étape à te rends
compte que si c'est des gens comme
d'autres horizons pour aucune différence
tout à fait il ya quelque chose qui
m'est qui m'est venue pendant pendant
qu'on pendant que tu racontes et en
anecdotes web à gstaad
j'étais encore chez mes parents québec
j'avais une copine capital image où
j'avais emprunté la cadillac de ma mère
pour aller chercher ma latent de ma
blonde en fait j'attends des cas
l'arrivée je te parquet dans une rue à
limoilou
puis je me rappelle il ya un policier
qui est venu ce que j'ai répondu à tous
ce n'est pas exact parce que oui ça
m'est arrivé une fois ils ont accepté
par un policier pour aucune raison qu'un
policier qui venait me voir
puis jetée dans une cadillac qui étaient
arrêtés les lumières rouler encore en
plein milieu dans limoilou merkel il
vient il vient boire plus qu'un apport
il est dit que c'est mais j'ai regardé
fait j'attends ma blonde
moi il me regarde il regarde et la
maison l'avant ou est ce qu'il y avait
j'ai comme pointer là une chambre
illuminé me regardait fait sont tout le
temps à lantin puis il m'a vu un
problème là un blanc ça va ça sexy
2012 ok 2012 tu vois moi j'avais un ami
ça fait un peu plus longtemps que ça
était chez eux dans limoilou chez sa
mère dans le parc est en train de
changer la plaque de sa voiture qui
venait d'acheter je pense que c'est un
caddie aussi cadillac change la plaque
la police est arrivée avec les gones
sortie juste pour ses bonnes sorties et
chez eux et chez eux en train de changer
la plaque de sa voiture tranquille
marcher ou à conserver les gones sortie
ouais juste pour mondeville 2 poids 2
mesures
sûrement même point de penser d'avoir
son arme avec lui le tchèque est venue
intercepte et maintenant c'est ça oui
comme ceux dits deux poids deux mesures
donc tu as été presque profiler presse
j'ai vu aussi puppy ça nous amènera à
parler de l'aspect ta vie musicale
j'ai vu une personne qui a partagé un
tweet dernièrement qu'il sait faudrait
vraiment que les américains commencent à
pulluler parler de l'amérique du nord
globalement faudrait vraiment qu'ils
aimeraient qu'elle commence à aimer les
noirs comme il aime la culture noire
puis c'est la culture noire c'est massif
et la musique mettons leur ras le bol
c'est la chose qui le plus écouté
mondialement en ce moment c'est
l'influencé de la musique noire
c'est plus que l'époque tg le blues qui
doit quitter donné naissance au rock
ce jeudi on en aurait pas eu de groupe
rock n'aurait pas eu de toute la musique
qu'on écoute la culture qu'on consomme
est tellement influencée de la culture
noire ok ça qui est omniprésente
oui puis toi même dans les années
ces années 50 quand l'europe commence il
ya des noirs déjà qu'ils faisaient du
rock
ç'a pris un elvis pour prendre zhenhua
pour ensuite les amener vers les blogs
skyrock et au flanc ça va le sait le
king est arrivé après exactement c'est
donc oui effectivement des éléments
culturels qui ont façonné le 20e siècle
le 21e siècle mais qui connaît mieux que
l'ailé ceux qui l'ont qu'ils ont fait
reste un peu plus loin à retourner aux
etats-unis une coupe de mieux disant des
données sans tourner aux états unis
jeter aux mines
si je me trompe h à l'université du
maine puis j'ai eu mes amis qui
m'accompagnait puis elle parlait que
monsieur là bas ils me suis dis parce
que mon ami aime beaucoup de basket wafa
qui parlait de basket puis monsieur dit
j'aime beaucoup le basket mais ya trop
de noirs mal pavy de regarder ce dans
quoi il ya beaucoup beaucoup de noirs
mais avec moins de noirs métis rouquin
un petit peu trop mais c'est ça mais
même pourquoi je vous jure jeu parfait
accent il veut ya quelques jours je sais
comme c'est venu dans ma tête comme mais
pourquoi
qu'est ce qui te dérange de voir des
gens avec un peu plus de mélanine
courait après un ballon c'est quoi le
problème
mais exactement donc je trouve ça fou
puis d'un point de vue culturel même
chose c'est que j'ai envie de glisser
momentanément vers le hip hop ici
comment les poches quand sa frappe en
1995 l'un des premiers à québec et se
prend au début des années 2000 la
plupart des personnes que tu voyais
qu'ils étaient commercialisés étaient
des personnes noires sans pression mosai
ont un niveau crevé un étrange et cetera
aujourd'hui regardons qui passe à la
radio qui est commercialisé toi et il
n'y a pas une personne noire aura 6 et
des personnes blanches etc des personnes
que
soit dit en passant que j'étais toujours
que je respecte parce que des amis
je pense à coria je pensais à la classe
je m'adresse paix pourra la classer
family commencé déjà que je considère
comme famille mais c'est des discussions
j'ai avec eux je dis même et vous
trouvez pas ce que on parle d'une
culture noire parce que les pop et une
culture noire mais qu' aujourd'hui le
public est exposée qu'à une partie où ce
sont des personnes blanches qu'ils font
ouais puis je dire j'ai dit ce que j'ai
dit ce que je suis pas en train de dire
c'est que seulement les noirs peuvent
faire sur un point les blancs peut
frapper aussi regarder limoilou starz
mon groupe
la moitié étaient blanches la moitié
était noir la question n'est pas si les
blancs peuvent faire du rap
la question c'est pourquoi est-ce que le
succès commercial en ce moment au québec
au 21e siècle en 2020 n'est que succès
commercial avec le rappeur blanc je pars
pas de succès de rua météo sommes de
grands nous on a des rappeurs noirs qui
ont beaucoup de succès homme de grand
mais qui passe à ckoi qui passent dans
les grandes radios qui est invité dans
les grandes émissions télé ça pour moi
c'est un grand mystère c'est c'est ici
on a un un podcast heures au studio qui
s'appelle adamo qui fait un podcast qui
s'appelle le temps ne juge donc une
bonne job au thc puis discutent avec des
gens principalement de la scène hip hop
puis il reçut des rappeurs street plus
underground puis et déjà des dégâts que
j'avais jamais entendu parler cada mode
veille
georges en revient pas on vient de
boucler is yes plume je sais qu'ils y
est mais je suis pas leur apporte de
grandes jupes aux grades la rue j'ai
aucune des ces qui il laisse plus tu vas
voir sources c'est shine puis sur sur
son you tube ou sur spotify son nom de
chemin depuis ces non massifs où des
millions et des millions déconnecte le
sde écoute que
possiblement coriace puis j'en ai jamais
entendu parler exact pipi samsam c'est
quand j'ai réalisé cela j'ai capoté
je comprenais pas pourquoi même chose
c'est comment qui s'appelle l'autre et y
est je pense que de descendance arabe à
moins que je me trompe mais il ya une
image mais il ya aussi les plus petits
le big business pasqua sa descendance
mais moi je suis quand j'ai réalisé ce
qui avait des dégâts qu'ils avaient des
ford ring énorme qui faisaient de la
musique incroyable qu'ils étaient nuls
bord le temps où ce deux poids deux
mesures jeu parce que ici on a une une
lecture double c'est à dire que je pense
qui est remarquablement une lecture dite
raciales entre guillemets justice
guillemets parce qu'on sait la race est
un concept est une construction sociale
mais c'est un mot qui fait que l'on est
obligé de même exactement parce qu'ils
étaient construits le mot fut le mot est
construit il est là mais il était
pourtant toujours de se rappeler que
c'est une invention qui datent de pas si
longtemps un bon je fais le dr
historique mais là le concept de race
née dans les années 1700 tu vois avant
1700 les gens parlent pas en terme de
race c'est seulement avec les années
1700 puis la classification des plantes
et des animaux ou des humains
couplé avec l' esclavage tout ce qu'on a
dit viser en race et hiérarchisé et donc
je pense que aujourd'hui pour faire
cette lecture là il ya cette question
dit raciale mais il ya aussi une
question sociale une question de classe
une lecture de classe affaire parce que
ce sont des gens qui viennent de deux
segments de la population qui n'est pas
représentée à la radio à la télé nous
c'est le segment de la population qu'on
veut pouvoir qui hantent groggy mais les
bas fonds tu vois pas soit sous le doigt
sur le jaqee succès énorme aussi mais
qu' on voit rarement dans ses réseaux là
parce que je pense que les gens n'ont
pas envie d'entendre parler
de limoilou c'est comme qu'elles ont pas
envie d'entendre parler de saint michel
ou de saint léonard ou de xy donc le
québec s'est façonné une identité
culturelle dans laquelle il n'y a pas de
place pour déjà issus de ces milieux là
ce que je pense c'est parce
qu'inconsciemment le grand public
québécois majoritairement blanc est plus
disert à s'identifier par se reconnaître
dans justement des des rapports qu'il la
fera sans moyens qui pas de réalité qui
leur parle moins 10 de fait ça c'est sûr
je pense que les gens le ressentent
moins s'identifie moins
toutefois ça veut pas dire qu'il devrait
pas y avoir de place
absolument d'un point de vue de rotation
dois je pense que c'est important que
tout le monde aussi est accès à ce pour
savoir qui allait céder ses réalités
l'heure ces personnes le existent ont
quelque chose à dire ils sont
pertinentes ou et puis qui amène un
message aussi d'une dune différences de
mode de vie c'est à dire que c'est une
vie qui complètement différente mais si
même dans la province dans la ville puis
je vous aurai une chose que je trouve
tellement insultante
c'est les directeurs de ces quads je
connais pas le nom qui m a donné il
était à tout le monde en parle
puis il dit bon set up je conseille
d'écouter la ddt que j'ai commencé à
comprendre mais là tu vois comme avant
ça je comprenais rien à rien le la dette
avait pu te couches comprenez c'est
comme c'est tellement insultant pour
tout le reste les aspects comme si tout
le monde marc monnet aussi l'un
maintenant mais pas exactement
exactement c'est juste que pour
possiblement cloud rap est sûr que sur
des affaires qui qui lui pouvait pouvait
comprendre comment une jarre de classe
moyenne blanche
c'est ça je pense que de ce point de vue
là c'est drôle parce que moi quand
j'étais jeune j'étais jeune je parle ya
vingt ans et 20 ans je disais toujours à
le jour où l'europe sera acceptée
socialement il y aura plus de
représentativité dans nos médias
moi c'est une grande naïveté
c'est drôle comment la culture qui émane
de montréal francophone du moins leur
ressemble plus à un exemple québec que
montréal finalement ces quatre gardés
mais diakhaté coûte les émissions
télévision
ça ressemble plus à un quotidien de deux
réalités des régions de québec plus
blanc tss tandis qu à montréal on se
rend compte que justement la réalité
puis les différences est vraiment
différente qui vraiment plus présent
tout autre qu'est ce qui dans les médias
un couple le meilleur exemple c'est il
ya trois ans pour fêter les les 350 ans
de montréal je sais même plus et les
jets avaient fait deux morts et a350 375
je me souviens plus 3,75 points et la
première annonce qu'ils ont fait j7
s'est fait controverse parce que les
seules personnes que tu voyais dans
l'annoncé des personnes blanche pour
parler de montréal c'est thomas c'est
exactement ce que je faisais à l'époque
j'ai ça c'est quelque chose qui aurait
pu être faire québec admettons mais que
ce soit fait à montréal c'est comme et
lyon mais vous foutez de la gueule de
qui en ce moment là et ceci je trouve
que ça a exposé justement ce manque de
pensée
quant à cette diversité en guinée tu
vois et ce manque de présence de cette
diversité dans les mains des organes
décisionnels parce que à l'époque
c'était je pense gilbert rozon qui
dirigeait le 375e et d'écouté gelé vue
puis je me suis jamais rendu compte de
sa toile certains dans la contrefaçon
est comme gelée vue puis je me suis
jamais rendu compte pour vous dire
comment s'est ancré en nous toi comment
ça on se rend pas compte que l'image est
frappante quand mettons d'une chanteuse
blanche tiré par un char tiré par des
personnes des gens comme ça les choses
comme ceux qui on le voit pas si on en
comprend paul
problématique non exactement ce que je
veux dire tellement créer deux semaines
comme cela c'est la même chose c'est
exactement le même contexte m donc il ya
un manque de littératie racisées ici
c'est à dire que les gens de la
difficulté à lire c'est ces différences
leurs différends la difficulté à lire
les pactes de leurs actions leurs
décisions aussi puiss et rétroactivement
qu'on s'en rend compte exact toujours
attendre exactement un an exactement
pitt et est aussi le palais paul danger
mais meetic s'est passé par exemple avec
avec justin trudeau pil pil blackface de
de juger avec un oeil d'aujourd'hui des
actions du passé ce ccco aussi une
problématique qui est nuancée par ce que
parce qu'à l'époque parlement d'une
action où est-ce qu'ils n'avaient pas la
conscience sociale autour de cette
action la même si l'action était de
notre oeil aujourd'hui on sait seulement
que c'est pas socialement acceptable ou
nuisibles à une cause expirait qu à
l'époque elle n'était pas nécessairement
sait où elle peut encore saisir souvent
on va prendre ce argument là pour
l'esclavagé mettons audio non mais dans
l'esclavagé tout le monde faisait ça à
l'époque
mais c'est pas vrai il ya des gens qui
étaient contre l'esclavagé moiselle cela
va laisser ça et donc mais c'étaient des
gens qui étaient perçus comme des
hurluberlus
il est perçu comme des extrémistes et
donc à chaque époque et toujours des
gens qui disent oui qu'ils disent qu'ils
sont elles que c'est ça qui sont contre
le mouvement général mais qui sont des
minorités etc et donc effectivement je
dire il ya vingt ans c'était pas commun
comme aujourd'hui
espérons que trudeau a fait du chemin
pour ce dernier moment exactement
mais voilà je pense que c'est ce que
c'est les choses changent eux puis on
doit apprendre de ces changements là
aussi avec dans le temps qui nous reste
invaincu doivent quitter dans le monde
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui s'en vient
pour toi si les gens qui ont écouté
cette conversation le veulent entendre
plus de toi veulent soit consommé tons
or ou écouter en conférences ou qu'est
ce qui suit qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui sont modifiées avec la avec la coved
lac la situation actuelle mais si les
gens veulent des coûté plus de suivre il
ya mon site internet
wester ls points comme what's left sur
instagram et facebook où je partage mes
différents projets j'ai sorti un ep avec
un groupe de jazz ce rappel fife au trio
là en avril passé un projet sur lequel
je travaille depuis quelques années avec
une certaine album ensemble l'année
passée vous sortez un p donc on avait
quelques concerts d'aligner la cet été
qui malheureusement ont été annulés donc
ce projet hybride jazz hip hop et font
une espèce de jazz plus prog rock
plainte et un choc à ses amis et à ses
collègues
c'est un projet complètement différent
que ce que j'ai pu faire des dernières
années sinon j'ai sorti des livres aussi
l'année passée un manuel d'écriture hip
hop qui s'appelle à londres des feuilles
toujours en librairie un lien manuel
l'écriture pour moi exact très content
pour enseigner en fait l'art de
l'écriture hip hop de l'analyse de texte
ou s'il va coûter biographique je
raconte mon parcours et j'ai sorti
l'année passée un livre jeunesse à
propos d'olivier lejeune le premier
reste la vie si donc si vous avez envie
d'écouter de la musique et ça ça me
faisait envie de lire
il se leva et des enfants il ya ça mais
le livre jeunesse c'est un livre que
pour les adultes aussi ce à dire que
vous pourriez le prendre lire aussi
trouver quelque chose c'est juste que
c'est sous le couvert de jeunesse donc
les gens peuvent suivre sur les
différents réseaux éventuellement il y
aura des concerts les conférences ont
revenir aussi il ya mes tours guidés qui
devrait recommencer cet été
un tour au québec historique sous ont
fait le vieux québec et on voit
l'histoire de la présence noire de l'
esclavage
à québec il ya encore des traces
visibles
oui et non c'est à dire que les lieux
existent mais y'a pas nécessairement de
traces c'est à dire qu'il ya quelques
bâtiments et quelques lieux où on peut
parler de cette histoire parce qu'elles
aient lieu sur la place même mais il n'y
a pas de pesticides précis en lien avec
cette histoire là malheureusement ça me
semble vraiment intéressant vous
viendrez écoute merci vraiment d'être
venu aujourd'hui d'avoir d'avoir étalé
tt tt connaissance puis on espère
sincèrement qu'il est et ce qui s'y
passe en ce moment puisque s'est passé
ça serait pas envie qu'il va avoir des
profonds changements que face aux péris
dans nos sociétés pis on travaille tous
dans cette direction tout à fait merci
de votre invitation c'est vraiment
apprécié puis je souhaite bonne ville
ont fui
merci